[Music]
i know
thank you very much
[Laughter]
thank you very much
thank you very much
wow
i want to say
it's great to be back in chicago home
home of the 1908 world championship
chicago cup
yay we did it
congratulations
thank you so much for that why am i in
chicago you ask i'm here for one reason
i'm here to fill the void left by oprah
i
i am your new oprah
great to be here what a fa andy what a
fantastic i know i know these are my
people
so great to be here nice to get out of
los angeles for a little bit i got to
tell you you know walking around chicago
so different from walking around l.a in
chicago you get to see real breasts
yeah
yeah sadly
yeah
sadly the biggest ones here are usually
on a man but uh
[Applause]
and they're here tonight hi fellas
you guys got a lot going on last weekend
was rib fest
yeah
and this week is bike to work week
which means next week is i just broke my
bike with my fat ass week
i'm looking forward to that smash it
a lot of controversy here too you aware
of this andy uh probably just pretend
probably covers you for just about
everything i went to rehearsal so yeah
yeah yeah i don't remember it now but
when you say it i'll remember it oh yeah
you you probably heard about this
illinois state rep derrick smith has
been accused of accepting a seven
thousand dollar bribe
yeah
yeah if he's found guilty he could serve
up to four years as the state's governor
it's a tradition
[Applause]
this is interesting did you know this
the last time i did uh a late night show
in chicago my guest was an up-and-coming
senator from the south side called
barack obama that's true true yeah
and yeah
and now
now just six short years later he's gone
on to become a socialist muslim from
kenya
it's the american dream
chicago native's been making the news
andy did you hear about this
probably
it's been reported that kanye west
is getting ready to propose to kim
kardashian
yeah
yeah today kanye said i can't wait to
marry kim and get started making the
worst family on earth
[Applause]
and international news uh this is
interesting british prime minister david
cameron has admitted he accidentally
left his eight-year-old daughter in a
pub
yeah cameron was immediately named an
honorary citizen of chicago
that's what we believe in
usa you
what's
what's wrong with you
what's wrong with them they're just
happy to be in air conditioning i know
exactly